you know we're talking about journalists
going on the ground and the safety of
those journalists what makes sense for
them
and maybe it's time to stop acting like
we're talking about protests
maybe it's time to start acting like
you're going into a war zone
across enemy lines quite literally if
these are people who have killed
this guy in portland is dead he was
killed by a guy with a big red salute on
his neck the black lives matter
communist symbol it's the red salute
it's crazy
shot a guy in the chest killed him if we
know that we are involved in what people
have called a cold
civil war that was this princeton
professor a democrat by the way
he said it was a cold civil war a couple
years ago and so the point now where
people have literally been
killed and many of some many others have
gone to prison in these in these fights
when you start treating these things
like there's there's no america right
now
maybe people just don't want to accept
it maybe we're desensitized to it but
let me explain something
i've talked for a while about civil war
and the left loves to disparage this
concept because they need
to make sure it's ridiculed if regular
americans wake up to the fact that their
way of life
their jobs and even their race just
based on their race they're being
attacked and disparaged
having their resources stripped away
well they might actually get mad about
that
so the left loves to say it's not true
it's never going to happen well
let's go through a few things you've got
in washington they're they're mandating
critical race theory
1619 project level stuff they're
literally telling children
a different history of the united states
that makes the u.s seem like evil like
an evil empire
they tell kids that the the country was
founded in 1619 as a slaveocracy
they are literally flying flags of their
ideology at our embassies
the embassy flies the american flag
because the american flag represents all
americans
half this country more than half
actually do
not support black lives matter you have
youth over half now well it's over half
because some are neutral and many oppose
it
so you've got like 48 supporting 48
opposing and then like 3 neutral which
means
more than half do not support and nearly
the same amount oppose it
yet our embassies are flying a flag of
an ideology opposed by half the country
you have schools putting out revisionist
history
you have the fleeing from from you know
the states are hyper polarizing
you have institutionalized ideologies
that are willing to lie
cheat and steal and accuse a president
of being a russian spy accuse people of
being white supremacists
and their goal is to make sure regular
americans don't
realize it's happening which brings me
to this story i want to show you
kids network nickelodeon rolls out pride
month content
with imagination i can be anything i
want now i don't care
too much like you know pride content
lgbt rights and all that stuff i've
actually campaigned for many of these
organizations don't you want to arm the
trans people
absolutely 100 they should all have guns
however the issue i'm talking about here
with this story is this
in the video they show what's called the
red salute
you know what the red salute is that's
right well you just did it oh no
that's right yeah and the chinese
communist party i love how you can do
this but you you can't you can't salute
you can't do the
mustache man but you can do this which
is actually worse but yeah that's right
they killed a ton of people they're all
they're all manipulative authoritarian
psychopaths and genocidal maniacs
and right now the chinese communist
party when they swear someone into the
party they
they perform the red salute nickelodeon
is showing the red salute to children
they're getting them to identify with
this ideology so it's time to stop
acting like antifa on the street or
anything other than
enemy belligerence they go around
destroying
buildings burning them down they've
literally killed people
i can already hear the left saying but
what about the far right who've killed
people
yes they're lunatics and bad as well
lock them all up and throw away the key
now now we can deal with the thousands
of people across this country black clad
antifa
who have been going on causing billions
of dollars in damage and we can ask our
state department politely
please don't fly the flag of this cult
dogma ideology that
half the country does not support by all
means you can believe in a bunch of
crazy things
some of these people like flying some of
the people in america they like flying
confederate flags not a big fan
some of these people like flying blm
facts flags oh youtube's gonna get me
that one
not a big fan just drop the l that was
the internet connection yeah
some of these people like flying flags
of a bunch of different ideologies
there's a flag for for islam or symbols
for these things
and i believe people should be allowed
to fly them i don't think our embassies
should be flying flags that do not
represent the country
however as we now know because this
woman on msnbc a new york times
editorial board member said she was
disturbed by the sight
of people with american flags because by
showing those flags they were basically
saying it's my country
and not yours which is a paranoid
delusion
but it comes a certain point when you
have
conflict in the streets for years where
people are being killed
skirmishes not a whole lot of death but
some death physical destruction of
property
attacks on on governmental institutions
and yes there was the the riot at the
capitol
you have these things happening and
united things happened americans
have are frogs in a pot boiling could
you imagine
if it was eight years ago if all of
these embassies around the world start
flying the black lives matter flag
people would be like whoa whoa what's
happening but they do it one step at a
time
and now americans are like no
everything's normal and fine like antifa
is a normal thing i'm used to it by now
yes you are used to the fact that black
clad leftist extremists go around
throwing bricks through windows and
burning buildings down
for over a year consistently and
sporadically for the years before that
that's not normal and now nickelodeon
is running commercials promoting that
ideology
there was on disney channel cassandra
fairbanks tells me about this they're
running
anti-trump commercials for children what
do you so so you can call it whatever
you want you can say we're not in a
culture war or conflict or a civil war
people have died already the conflict is
only escalating
and now you have joe biden you know
engaging in
these behaviors you have our embassies
around the world flying a flag that
doesn't represent this country
and i'm like now we're at a point where
the american flag
is being flown and just below it black
lives matter
how long until they say we're going to
take the american flag down just for one
day
in honor of black lives matter half mass
how long until they say well we're going
to put the american flag at half mass
but we support
you know black lives so we'll fly black
lives matter how long until they say
well we don't want to use the words
we're going to do the fist how long
until they say
it's the communist salute and you're
going to the gulag
perhaps it'll never happen perhaps it's
all just chilling out
and this right now this everything we're
seeing with nickelodeon promoting the
red salute
with these children's programs saying
orange man bad with violence in the
streets and andy no getting beat up
maybe this is the moment where
everything stops
and tomorrow everyone calms down the
only problem
every time i've said that it just gets
worse and keeps
escalating you're kind of feeding my
conspiracy theory that black lives
matter and antifa are working together
i don't know how you guys feel about
that black lives matter gets the picture
on the flag then antifa uses that
picture to justify their behavior
yep they co-opt their movement though i
think it's the antifa
members specifically and i always just
say members because they are they are
allegiant to an idea
who are the actual people who are
committing a lot of the destructive
damage at these events
uh but they use the cover of black lives
mattering to
be dismissed right because their their
goals are cultural marxist goals
are to relieve the the oppressed and so
somehow
americans should feel like small
businesses being destroyed is a justif
justified response
to trying to help black people which is
absolute stupidity the fact that people
think that black people need help and
it's their job to help them
is so asinine and ridiculous i mean
i have become so emboldened with
everyone talking about how black people
need help and how black people need this
or that
it's like you know what how about you
stop looking at black people like a
monolith of just like this group of
people that need help and start
realizing
people are individuals and there are
cultural trends and things that can be
addressed
but it's just if we could stop calling
them black people that would also be
great and then we called
people of color too you know now it's
even more except for asians are no
longer in there because they're white
powers
listen they they don't care about those
people the left does not care
it is white progressives mainly their
upper class or from the suburbs
they don't care about the black
community they don't care about the
asian community
they don't care about ending asian hate
they can march around all day and that
would stop asian hate flags and then go
beat up andy no sorry it doesn't work
that way
they're perpetuating it because what
they really want to do regular people
are the target
so when i say civil war they say what a
crazy [ __ ] because they don't want
regular people to actually listen to
what's happening
so i don't say it all the time but i say
it a lot because i think a lot of people
need to recognize what it is
semantics are important the left will
call their no-go zones
autonomous zones it sounds so funny it's
autonomous zone
say no go zone they're not autonomous
zones they're areas the cops are scared
to enter
where people are being killed george
floyd square they call it no i call that
an extremist no-go zone that's all i
call it that's it a far left extremist
no goes on why
people are being shot and killed bullets
are riddling up these buildings
and the cops don't want to go there but
but here's the point though that flag
is the american flag now whether you
like it or not because intersectionality
this idea of bringing minority groups
together
for one common goal is the result of the
reality that multiculturalism
does not work it does not work to have a
country
that is divided up into sub classes of
people who want a different outcome for
the nation
at equal or greater powers or strengths
that does not work with a bio spirit of
a nation
of people wanting an outcome if you want
an outcome for a nation to be successful
or an empire this is why empires when
they over
reach or over expand their territory
kind of falling apart there's too much
to manage too many wants and desires
from too many groups
and they lose focus but i'm just saying
this that that flag
and the reason why it keeps expanding i
don't know if you saw today that they
changed it again
to add a circle for intersex people on
the left-hand side
the point is actually pushing the
rainbow out see yes this is my point
is this intersectionality is great
because what they see as being this
white conservative straight roadblock to
this
one world order that they think is a
nationalist identity
they need to remove that but they
haven't had enough power to remove that
and even the boogeyman of white
supremacy
is pretty much ridiculous but what they
do is now they incentivize you
though saying like you're just like you
you think it's cool to be an american
and patriotic
wait till you're gatriot you know and
you actually get on this on this train
and you join us have you ever had a
weird thought about the same sex
oh you're probably queer you think black
lives matter
you're now a blm supporter and it's like
these like basic things that
humans have gone through and they start
to procure you into saying
your identity is with us and they create
a sub
culture from america that is the
amalgamation of all of the micro
cultures
and in fact they have become more
influential and more powerful
than this white sub dominant silent
majority that everyone talks about that
doesn't actually exist
and so you know it's funny and then
whenever they talk about this right like
the white replacement theory or these
things
they'll say these are conspiracy
theorists but then you hear the left
talk about this stuff like to understand
the future of the countries to
understand
immigration and to understand people of
color moving in and they talk about
these things and when you bring them
back up
you get called a conspiracy theorist why
it's because their ultimate goal is to
subvert and undermine
our culture our society they're using
that by taking advantage of these people
who are outcasts
they're creating that mixed with a lack
of assimilation and they are dominating
and now they're flying their flags
in our embassies that is we've been
conquered
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you